some cars maintain a classic design and
style through the years that's certainly
the case with the jeep wrangler which
made its debut way back in nineteen
eighty six at the time the wrangler was
made by american motors now it's built
by Fiat Chrysler
yeah reg nuggets or our Auto testify
know Dyson 04 says that the Wrangler
looks like one of those indestructible
US army chiefs from World War two the
Wrangler is pretty tough too and it's
one of the last true off-road vehicles
on the market the wrangler rubicon model
is available with either a diesel or a
standard gasoline engine neither is
particularly environmentally friendly
the one word testing has a co2 output of
237 g/km our Wrangler costs forty four
thousand euros which is quite a bit to
pay for a car that's not exactly on the
cutting edge of design and technology
the best part about the Wrangler is that
you can take it out and get it dirty it
wasn't built for cruising around cities
and if you get into trouble somewhere
out in the middle of nowhere the
Wrangler comes equipped with a spare
wheel
in an all gold on the inside you still
have the trademark grab handle on the
glove compartment introduced in 1941
that's what I legged here's the transfer
case off-road gear reduction and of
course the sway bar and axle lock
switches enabling the vehicle to do more
than most drivers in countries like
Germany there aren't too many places
where you can really push the Wrangler
to its limits over in the u.s. fans
rebel and crossing their own personal
Rubicon in there Rubicon no wonder with
a ground clearance of some 26
centimeters
this is where the old school engineering
rolls back the years it's hard to think
of a contemporary SUV with the talents
to master surface is this tricky embark
ments twisted terrain and streams are no
problem for the Rubicon it can plow
through rivers up to seventy seven
centimeters deep that's because the
engine intake is so far up but it's
protected from sucking in water although
the handling and chassis leave no doubt
as to whether this baby prefers
cross-country to the autobahn the high
center of gravity coupled with the leaf
spring suspension and the huge tires
hardly bodes well for the Rubicon's
corner handling the Wrangler is an
automotive dinosaur that isn't remotely
interested in modern trends at the end
of the day it does what it was built to
do to get the driver to their
destination however challenging the
route there
you